If you're anything like me you like the idea
of reading but when it actually comes time
to buckle down sit on a chair pick up a book
and read you have a hard time focusing let
alone really enjoying it.
And maybe you've thought to yourself "Well,
I guess I'm just not a reader.
I'm more of an action-based learner, you know,
I learn by doing."
But deep down you know that by not reading
books you're missing out on some of the important,
in depth and profound insights ever recorded.
So how can people like us, people who aren't
naturally bookworms, actually read books,
retain their information, and actually learn
to enjoy it?
Well in this video I'm going over 5 powerful
strategies that will help you not only read
more, but find that you enjoy reading more
than you ever possibly thought you ever could.
Tip number one: If you want to start reading,
don't overachieve.
It's very easy to say "yeah I'm gonna read
a book a week from now on."
But your past is telling.
You're not going to.
So in order to break into the habit of reading,
you need to set your standards almost comically
low.
I'm talking one page a day.
Reading one page only takes about 60 seconds
if you're an average-speed reader, and, well,
it's an extremely easy task.
But remember: It's just as easy not to do,
so make sure you do it.
Don't make not doing it an option.
And if you want to keep reading after you've
read your daily page - go for it, but the
important thing is to get that one page in.
Tip number two is: read before going on the
internet.
You don't need me to tell you that the internet
is an ADHD inducing place full of cheap dopamine
highs and shallow thinking.
Checking your Facebook, Instagram, Pinterest
and Reddit before reading a good book is like
binge eating Skittles before tasting a fine
wine.
The wine will taste way worse and you'll feel
too sick to drink it anyways.
Point being - read books before your brain
is zapped by the internet.
A great way to do this, obviously, is to read
first thing in the morning.
Which brings me right to my next tip.
Tip number three is bunch your habits.
Habit bunching is when you pair an already
existing habit that you enjoy doing with a
habit that you're trying to work on.
If it's a habit for you to drink a nice hot
cup of coffee in the morning, then pair that
habit with reading.
An easy way to do this is to put the book
you want to read next to your coffee maker
in the morning so when you get up and make
yourself a cup of coffee you'll see the book
and you'll grab it and go.
By bunching an already existing habit with
one you're trying to work on, not only will
it be easier to work on that new habit but
the enjoyability of the first habit may even
rub off on the second one.
Tip number four is: Try audiobooks.
Listening to audiobooks is a great way to
soak in the information of a book while still
being able to multitask.
One of my favorite things to do, especially
if I have to read a book for school, is to
listen to the book while I'm working out.
If you enjoy working out like I do this counts
as habit bunching.
My camera just overheated.
Where was I. Audible is personal favorite
place to get audiobooks and while the subscription
isn't free.
Oh yeah!
So if you find yourself at about a book-a-month
pace then audible's free book system pays
for itself.
I think that math checks out.
My fifth and final tip is: Change your attitude.
And this tip, while it may seem not very practical
or hands on, it's probably the most important.
Because if you self-identify as someone who
hates reading, you're building up unnecessary
mental resistance towards something you're
trying to do more of.
That's dumb.
So if you start identifying as someone who
enjoys reading, you'll break down mental barriers,
and you'll find the previous four tips a lot
easier to do.
So there you go.
Hopefully you find these tips as useful as
I currently do.
I used to be someone who didn't like reading...
Reading is not a hard activity in and of itself
because you're just kind of looking and understanding
paper.
But in this day and age with so many distractions,
especially because of the internet - it definitely
is a lot more difficult to eliminate those
distractions and just focus on doing something
a little slower-paced for a while.
And while I'm definitely not a book worm right
now, these tips definitely helped me get to
a point where I'm regularly reading good books
and making myself smarter and I feel a lot
better because of it.
If you liked this video be sure to hit that
like button.
If you like videos like these in general hit
that subscribe button.
Leave a comment because I love seeing your
comments and I respond to all of them I don't
know why I'm doing so many hand gestures.
Follow me on Twitter.
I have a lot of social media linky-dinks right
here - no - right here.
If you don't follow me on all my social media
- just follow me on Twitter because if you
want to ask me a question, I'm regularly on
there so it's by far the easiest way to communicate
with me (@BetterIdeasTV).
Thanks for watching and we'll catch you in
the next video.